On va faire le point avec Tamara
et Jean-François. Bonsoir à vous
deux.
- Bonsoir.BoBoBoBonsoir Céline.
- Jean-François, vous revenez
tout juste d'Ukraine. Bon
retour. Alors je vais commencer
avec vous parce que vous avez
côtoyé des militaires, des
Ukrainiens. Quel est l'état
d'esprit après trois mois
de guerre?
- C'est particulier, Céline,
pae e e e ça change d'abord en
fonction de là ou on se trouve
en Ukraine. Évidemment, dans
l'ouest du pays, on se sent
moins concerné par la guerre. On
est moins directement au contact
avec, avec l'ennemi, à part
évidemment des missiles qui
tombent ici et là. Mais on a vu,
par exemple, des gens qui
fêtaient dans les rues de Lviv,
qui prenaient des jeunes hommes
même en âge de se battre, qui
prenaient une bière q
jusqu'à l'arrivée.
- Ils ne sont pas mobilisés
encore.
- Exactement. Donc, et alorsilis
fantômes comme Kharkiv, les gens
fuient et ceux qui sont là,
vraiment, il n'y a presque pas
de restaurant ouverts, c'est
beaucoup plus tendu. Mais je
vous dirais qu'il y a quand même
une confiance assez inébranlable
de la part des soldats qui, eux,
sont convaincus qu'ils vont
gagner parce qu'ils sont
convaincusalalalalalement, ils
ont raison. Ils défendent leur
pays. Et puis, ils sont aussi
renforcés dans leurs convictions
parce qu'ils ont enregistré des
conquêtes sur le terrain. Il y a
évidemment Kiev, ils ont
repoussé l'ennemi de ce côté-là.
À Kiev, c'est plutôt eseseseses
qui sont retirés. Mais à
Kharkiv, c'est vraiment une
victoire de l'armée ukrainienne
arararararartillerie. On a réusi
à repousser les Russes jusqu'à
jusqu'à la frontière avec la
Russie. Et ça, ça a vraiment
fait monter en flèche le moral
des troupes, c'est clair.
- Et du côté russe, qu'est-ce
qu'on peut dire que la Russie aa
fait certains gains?
- Oui, elle n'est pas là ou elle
voulait être, mais au kilomètre
carré, là, oui, il y a des
gains. Il y a deux villes
stratégiques, dont Marioupol,
qui est un port, Kherson, qui
est stratégique pour l'entrée en
Crimée par voie terrestre, qui
sont en ce moment occupées
complètement par l'armée russe.
C'est l'armée russe qui qui les
contrôles ces villes-là. Et vous
savez, les images qui roulent
en boucle, c'est ça qui est
important à la télévision russe.
Pour le public russe, c'est les
images des soldats russes qui se
promènent dans ces villes-là où
on veut instaurer le rouble, où
le drapeau russe flotte sur less
écoles, où on va avoir des
référendums ou carrément pas,
veulent peut être annexer ces
territoires-là. Ça, c'est des
victoires symboliques pour
Vladimir Poutine, parce que ça
lui permet encore de justifier
sa guerre auprès du peuple
russe. Parce que c'est évident
qu'à défaut de l'avoir remporté
facilement et rapidement
sa guerre.
- Comme il l'espérait au début.
- Comme il l'espérait, s'il la
remporte, ça va être sur le long
terme. Et le très long ter
en parle souvent. On va attendre
ça souvent comme terme; une
guerre d'usure. Qu'est ce que ça
veut dire une guerre d'usure,
pour le Kremlin? En tout cas,
quand on écoute la télévision
russe encore, où les gens, vous
savez, les analystes paradent
sur ces plateaux, ces grandsplax
heures de grande écoute et
continuent à dire que l'Ukraine
ne mérite pas d'exister,
que l'Ukrainien ne mérite pas
d'exister en tant que langue,
que le peuple ne mérite pas
d'exister en tant que
Alors, comment on peut
s'imaginer qu'une guerre va
finir sans gains importants?
Je pense qu'on est en train de
préparer la population pour une
guerre d'usure. Et ce que ça
veut dire, c'est épuiser les
forces ukrainiennes. Si
possible, puisqu'on a vu leur
ténacité. Éventuellement à
tester la patience et la volonté
des alliés de l'Ouest d'aider
l'Ukraine à coups de milliards.
Donc, c'est ça, c'est vers ce
qu'on se dirige en ce moment.
- Etieieieieieieieieiens,
c'est une phase difficile de
la guerre. Volodymyr Zelenski
l'a dit, on re
jours prochains, ça va être
difficile. Les combats dans le
Donbass, c'est difficile pour
l'armée ukrainienne. Mais est-ce
qu'on pourrait imaginer qu'il
cèderait un jour ces
territoires? Parce que c'est ça
que Monsieur Kissinger dit en
fait.
- Difficile Céline aujourd'hui
d'imaginer Volodymyr Zelensky
annoncer à la population,
un accord de paix signé dans
lequel, par exemple, il
renoncerait à la Crimée dans
laquelle il renoncerait au
Donbass. Vous savez, il y a eu
un échange avec le président
Macron dans lequel ça a été
évoqué. Cette question-là. Le
contenu de la conversation entre
le président ukrainien et le
président français s'est
retrouvé un peu partout dans la
presse commentée par les
chroniqueurs dans lesquels,
apparemment, le président Macron
aurait demandé, aurait dit au
président Zelenski qu'il
faudrait peut être commencer
à songer à faire quelques
concessions pour permettre
à Vladimir Poutine de sauver la
face. Et ça, une des raisons
pour laquelle ça a fuité dans
la presse et parce que c'était
visiblement quelque chose
d'absolument inacceptable pour
le président. Et à l'unisson,
tous les Ukrainiens ont dit:
"Ah non, hors de question, bien
sûr que non. C'est
inacceptable." Et ce serait très
difficile effectivement
aujourd'hui pour Volodymyr
Zelensky de vendre ça à sa
population parce qu'on est dans
une guerre de survie, une guerre
existentielle et au fur et à
mesure que le coût est... plus,
il est lourd, le coût humain,
le coût économique, plus. Ça va
être difficile donc finalement
de renoncer à la totalité du
territoire ukrainien. Et puis
là, on assiste à un moment
charnière actuellement. Vous
l'avez dit, si le président
Zelenski a dit à la population:
"Attention, ça va être
difficile, ça va être long".
C'est parce qu'on est un petit
peu sur l'euphorie d'avoir
repoussé les Russes. Mais là,
maintenant, on s'installe dans
une guerre de position dans le
Donbass. Et oui, les Ukrainiens
ont enregistré des gains avec
les armes occidentales, avec par
exemple les pièces d'artillerie
données par le Canada, par les
États-Unis, avec évidemment les
armes en titane. Mais ça, ça a
servi dans une première étape,
ça a permis de freiner
l'avancée. Mais après ça, pour
lancer une contre offensive,
c'est une autre paire de
manches, beaucoup plus difficile
de regagner du terrain et ça,
ça risque d'être beaucoup plus
coûteux en vies.
- C'est pour ça que le président
demande à nouveau des armes,
des livraisons d'armes.
Et ça presse. Parce qu'ils en
ont besoin.
- Exactement, oui, mais le
problème, c'est qu'il ne suffit
pas d'avoir des armes. Il faut
former les soldats pour utiliser
ces armes-là. Ça prend du temps.
Le Canada à former des
Ukrainiens pendant des mois et
des mois, ça a servi. Mais après
ça, si on veut reformer toute
une nouvelle génération de
soldats à utiliser des armes et
des armes occidentales, ça ne
sera pas du jour au lendemain.
Donc c'est pour ça que le
président Zelenski dit:
"Attention, on y est pour
longtemps." Ce qui se dit sur le
terrain, on nous dit les gens
disent: "On espère avoir une
victoire avant la fin de
l'année." Mais quel type
de victoire?
- Quel type de victoire aussi,
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire?
Jean-François a dit quelque
chose d'important: sauver la
face, permettre à Poutine de
sauver la face. Posez-vous la
question qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire si on lui permet de trouver
une porte de sortie honorable
dans cette guerre? Ça veut dire
qu'on cautionne finalement tout
ce qu'on lui reproche depuis
des mois; les crimes de guerre
supposés qu'on est en train
d'enquêter, la destruction
massive. Vous avez vu de quoi a
l'air Marioupol. Les
bombardements. Donc quel message
et quel précédent, surtout on
crée si on lui permet de signer
un traité quelconque, de lui
céder des territoires
officiellement. D'abord, est-ce
qu'on peut faire confiance à la
signature de Vladimir Poutine en
2022? Qu'est ce qu'elle vaut
cette signature? Je pense que
beaucoup de gens se posent la
question après les les mensonges
qu'il a perpétrés en tout cas
à Macron à Shultz, durant
les semaines qui ont mené à la
guerre. Ça, c'est une chose. On
l'a laissé annexé la Crimée, on
l'a laissé financer une guerre
dans le Donbass. Beaucoup se
disent que si ça n'avait pas été
le cas, on en serait pas ou est-
ce qu'on en est en Ukraine
aujourd'hui. Je pense que pour
être vu voir les troupes
ukrainiennes ou le président
céder du territoire à ce stade
ci, outre ce qu'il y a, ce que
la Russie possédait avant le 24
février, c'est inimaginable pour
le moment.
- Et difficile, très
difficilement acceptable pour
les Ukrainiens. Après tout,
leurs sacrifices, on le comprend
bien, mais ça va dépendre
évidemment de l'aide
occidentale.
- Totalement, oui, d'abord de
l'aide, on l'a dit beaucoup
en armes, mais aussi de l'aide
économique, parce que la Russie
a été peu touchée finalement par
les sanctions. Il faut le dire,
le rouble a remonté, touché à
hauteur de 5 à 10 % peut être
alors que l'Ukraine, l'économie
ukrainienne va se rétracter de
45 %.
- Elle est asphyxie en ce
moment.
- Exactement, c'est impossible
de faire rentrer sortir les
biens, c'est très très difficile
avec le port d'Odessa et le
blocus de la mer Noire. Vous
l'avez vu, vous avez vu Céline
à la frontière, les queues de
camions qui attendent parfois.
- Des heures et des heures.
- Donc ça veut dire aussi une
aide économique pour soutenir
l'économie de l'Ukraine, ça veut
dire, est-ce que l'Occident va
avoir la patience et l'énergie
pour pouvoir continuer d'appuyer
ce conflit-là, continuer
d'appuyer l'Ukraine dans ce
conflit-là et continue d'appuyer
à long terme.
- Et il y a toute l'inconnue.
Une des grandes inconnues, c'est
la santé de Vladimir Poutine.
On en parle beaucoup.
- Tous les aspects de la vie
privée de Vladimir Poutine,
y compris sa santé, c'est un
coffre fort en Russie, fermé à
double tour. Il y a énormément
de rumeurs depuis quelques
semaines, depuis que la guerre a
commencé sur son état de santé.
Comme quoi il aurait un cancer
qu'il est régulièrement visité
par des oncologues. On ne sait
pas si c'est vrai. Il y a une
vidéo de lui ce week-end avec
Loukachenko, on le voit
trembler. En fait, pour garder
vraiment l'oeil nu, ça ne se
voit pas trop. Mais ceci dit,
je pense que toutes les
spéculations autour de son état
de santé viennent du fait que
pour beaucoup, il n'y a qu'une
seule façon de finir ce conflit-
là; c'est la disparition de
Vladimir Poutine, si pas sa
mort, mais très certainement le
voir perdre le pouvoir, ce qui
en ce moment n'est pas une
option dans la mesure ou il
n'est pas contesté et de la même
façon que on ne sait pas quels
sont les paramètres pour une
victoire pour Vladimir Poutine,
on peut présumer qu'il n'a pas
abandonné; son but initial était
de d'éventuellement occuper
toute l'Ukraine. Il est encore
très loin de ça, mais ça ne veut
pas dire que parce qu'il se
concentre dans l'Est
aujourd'hui, qu'il n'étendra pas
la guerre éventuellement, comme
il l'a fait au début vers
l'ensemble de l'Ukraine.
- Alors à suivre. Merci beaucoup
à vous deux. C'était vraiment
très intéressant.
- Merci, au revoir